hello my name is Sarah James I've been
working the past seven years at MIT
Lincoln Laboratory doing radar signal
processing today I'm here to tell you
about the image processing workshop of
the girls who build so the image
processing section of this workshop is
actually done with a software called
processing processing is open source
free and it's available at processing or
to download for just about any sort of
operating system that you can think of
this software is actually developed for
people that are not doing coding
day-to-day during this section of the
workshop we're trying to expose
participants to image processing
concepts within the context of real
world applications furthermore we're
trying to demystify coding and show
participants that they can do this too
you'll be doing four exercises the first
being an Instagram filter for the
Instagram filter this will be adding an
overlay where you can change the RGB
values next you'll be flipping an image
this will be a flip that's vertical and
during this you'll be actually moving
around the individual pixels after this
you will convert a color image to a
different color scheme so you'll take
something and convert it to one single
color this involves modifying the
individual color values for every pixel
for the last exercise which is the
vignette this is adding a border to the
picture the way that this is performed
is by doing a mask overlay before you
just jump in to having the girls doing
the fill in the blank exercises it's
highly recommended to go over the four
primary processing components of any
processing program the first is variable
declaration this is where you initialize
something as being a p image or perhaps
a boolean depending on the exercise next
is the set up the set up is where you
generally load in images and initialize
the various settings for a program after
that you'll have a draw draw is where
you actually produce the frame that
you'll see lastly you'll have in some of
the exercises mouse clicked and this is
to handle mouse click events before
breaking the girls up into groups we
add a image processing lecture that was
specifically tailored towards the
processing language during this lecture
various fundamentals of image processing
were introduced like color schemes for
instance RGB or things like HSB and
discussing brightness after the
processing lecture we broke up the girls
into groups of four with one volunteer
per group when the girls were broken up
they were given their exercises these
exercises were set up as
fill-in-the-blank activities the fill in
the blank style was done to kind of
level the playing field so that people
with more or less experience with coding
we feel comfortable time permitting and
also dependent on the experience level
of the girls that you're working with
there's additional activities that you
can do within the context of the for
coding exercises that have already been
defined for the first one for your build
your own Instagram filter you can
actually modify the RGB values to change
that overlay so this is something that's
relatively easy to do and something that
you should definitely encourage the
girls to do for the flip and image you
can actually change the way that the
images flips so in exercises that we had
the images flip vertically but a more
difficult thing that you can ask the
girls to do is to flip the image
horizontally so within the convert an
image to a single color you can actually
ask the girls to merely convert to
grayscale for this activity this is
something that's introduce the girls to
the way that color is perceived by
humans for the add a vignette one really
relatively easy thing that you can ask
the girls to do is vary the size and
color of the vignette lastly and this is
the most difficult you can actually ask
the participants to confine all elements
from all of the exercises this is
something that is the most complex
because it involves potentially changing
the way that the code was originally run
in the exercises so in terms of the
lessons learned there are certain things
that we did not do during girls who
build and in hindsight we would have
done if we were to do this again one of
the first thing
is actually introducing the fundamentals
of programming things like introducing
if statements while statements what a
boolean is things like that when we had
done girls who build that we kind of
just jumped right into the exercises
after an image-processing lecture and
that wasn't really enough preparation
for the girls the first exercise was
very difficult to get through that's
another thing that you could potentially
do if you have people that are not
really experienced with coding feel free
to go through the first exercise
together and then have the students do
the following three exercises
individually each individual student had
their own laptop don't think that this
is something that you need to do you may
find that having multiple students with
only one laptop will be sufficient and
actually might introduce them to working
in a group and the type of collaboration
that entails also along those lines if
everyone has their own computer you
might find that it's very isolating one
thing that girls who bill did not do but
it's something that we may look into in
the future is using some sort of
collaborative editing software an
example of this is tightened pad whether
you're a student or a teacher you may be
asking yourself where the next steps the
next steps could possibly be looking
into other coding languages coding
languages that you may want to look into
include C++ Java or Python you'll find
that for instance if you wanted to build
an Android app there's communities and
resources available online for free that
you can access
you
you